you're dreaming of buying a home here
are three steps to help you
first get your finances in order the big
question to ask yourself should you rent
or should you buy if you plan to move
within the next three to five years the
general view is that you should still
rent lenders and housing regulators
generally recommend spending no more
than 31 of your monthly income on
housing
and then there's the big one the down
payment that's the amount of cash that
you need to secure your home the more
you put down the less you have to
borrow some loan programs allow
first-time buyers to put as little as
three percent down but usually it's
between 5 and 20 of the purchase price
you'll want to get your credit score in
tip top shape
and get pre-approval for a mortgage that
way if you see a home you love you'll be
able to convince the buyer that you're
able to borrow the money from the bank
and beat anyone else to it
second go out onto the open market this
step is a little more fun do research on
the neighborhood where you think you
want to live go there maybe even stay in
an airbnb if you can afford it scope out
neighboring homes if you can go to open
houses maybe even find a real estate
broker you might need it in this hot
market bidding wars where hopeful buyers
offer above the asking price are
increasingly common finally try to
figure out what the neighborhood might
be like think not just what it looks and
feels like but also what your commute
could be like
then proceed to this next step very
cautiously closing the deal when you
find a home that you love that works
that you know you can afford make a
solid offer your general rule of thumb
offered just a bit but not too much
under the asking price that might be
about five percent but read the market
if bidding wars are common this just
might not work and you need to be
willing to negotiate
once a seller has accepted your price
you'll need to make what's called an
earnest payment of about one to two
percent to show you're serious about
buying this will go into an escrow
account held by a third party until the
transaction's complete in this final
stage you'll likely need a lawyer to
help you do some paperwork make sure
you're getting the best deal and stay
out of any legal trouble with the help
of your lawyer and your real estate
agent you'll want to conduct some
serious inspections of the property to
make sure there are no defects or other
problems once the checks are done your
financing is cleared and you've signed
on the dotted line the house is yours
and you can stop scrolling on that phone
at least for houses good luck